Film Courage: The ideal length of a YA novel?
Word count wise?
What’s the typical length and then if you
stretch it, what’s to be expected?
Jennifer Brody: That’s actually a great
question and that was something I was obsessed
about when I first started writing because
I know I tended to write long.
I know other people write shorter.
I would say the sweet spot (at least in my
opinion) is somewhere between 75,000 and 85,000
words for contemporary YA (which is a story
told in the here and now).
You will see books that are shorter, so you
can even get away with 65,000 words.
Or obviously longer than that.
If you start to go above 100,000 words (and
my book definitely does), the first book is
somewhere in the 105,000 word count range
comparable to something like HUNGER GAMES.
As the series progresses where you will get
more leeway on word count, they do span upwards.
I’m looking at 120,000 words on the third
book.
Like I said, when you’re doing big word
building genre books like sci fi fantasy,
you do get more leeway on word count regardless
of genre.
So you can get away with something that is
over 100,000 words.
But if you’ve never sold a book before and
you’re going on submission, I would caution
you on doing anything that is too much longer
than 100,000 to 105,000 because that’s a
pretty hefty book.
That said…I mean everyone has sold things
that are different lengths.
And I always think that the word count should
be justified by the story.
I did learn that when you write multiple POVs
that this will balloon your word count, that’s
why GAME OF THRONES is so long.
I have a lot of empathy of George R.R.
Martin.
But there is a reason why his books are spanning
over a 1,000 pages because once he starts
telling all those multiple stories really
it’s going to expand it.
But yeah, so the sweet spot for word count
is going to be somewhere in those ranges.